okay so let's talk about what we're
going to cover today so I want to cover
three main points first you are not an
imposter second feelings are not facts
and third I want to get over and break
out of that self-doubt infinite loop so
let's talk about some ways to do that
over four years ago I was thinking about
these thoughts wondering what's
happening in my field and where I fit in
and why I felt this way and so I made
this really crude diagram it's not even
aligned properly but I just did it just
to help me understand my my own thoughts
and it got a lot of traction and when
Wil Wheaton retweeted it I thought I
made it in the world I'm done so I kind
of want to unpack this a little bit more
especially in the tech world because as
we as we learn about what's out there
and and the frameworks that are
available and new technology then we we
know that the things that we don't know
starts to get larger and larger and what
I hope that you'll leave with is that
it's your intersection of different
things that you know you're experienced
in your perspective that brings you
value researchers showing a lot about
70% of folks feel this way
and I venture to guess that in the tech
world it's probably a lot more because
we're surrounded by smart people and we
are constantly bombarded with new
thoughts and new ideas so let's look a
little bit differently I like to think
of confidence as on a spectrum and any
given day will move back and forth on
this spectrum depending on where we are
lives in our career so on the left here
we have you know the very low confidence
my works never good enough
everyone knows more than I do I
and on the right we have the really high
maybe overly confident person who's
always perfect and thinks they're
smarter than everyone and they should be
the one in charge now I want to talk
about what reality is they're real
competence so if we have a mismatch here
between the way the way you feel about
the world your your confidence in your
work and your actual competence then
there's a danger here of what we're
calling impostor syndrome of course
there could be a mismatch the other
direction which is the dunning-kruger
effect where you're really highly
confident but not really highly
competent so but today we're going to
talk about this particular mismatch
where you have a low confidence going
into something and but really you are
very competent which I venture to guess
most of you are so some signs that we
see here you know downplaying
accomplishments you feeling like
everything that you do that it's
successful is luck you're not sure if
you're good enough to work here everyone
seems really smarter than me this all
could lead to some negative impacts your
work suffers you may even suffer
physical things like ulcers back pain
migraines anxiety relationship issues
all because of this this fear and this
anxiety in 2011 dr. Valerie young in her
book the secret thoughts of successful
women talked about five competency types
which I like to call personas that kind
of embody the different ways that
impostor syndrome can manifest itself
the first way we see here is this
perfectionist someone who sets extremely
high expectations for themselves
impossible to reach and every time they
make a small mistake they question their
own competence the expert someone who
feels like they have to know everything
complete all the details before they'll
even start a project apply for a job or
do anything they're afraid
to ask questions even because asking
questions might reveal some bit of their
own incompetence the the natural genius
maybe grew up things came easy so when
things don't come easy then I must be a
failure
the soloist feels like I must do
everything on my own and if I have to
ask if I have to ask for help then I'm
just not competent and finally we have
the super human who feels like I have to
really compensate for my incompetence by
just working really hard around the
clock so which one of these do you most
relate to this is me at least at some
point you know I kind of move back and
forth between these things so I want to
talk a little bit about bias and bias is
a lot like a colored lens that changes
the inputs that we get from the real
world and stores them in our brain in a
different way than we actually received
them but we don't know this happens and
you see that that red dot the congruent
belief is something that is already
consistent with our current belief
system our current feelings that is
fast-tracked right to the right right
into the brain yes I knew that was
correct goes right over there
the other ones take a little bit more
time and when we get a congruent belief
that makes our belief system even bigger
even stronger this is called
confirmation bias will even look for
things that are consistent with our
current beliefs and the confirmation
bias will also take contradictory
beliefs and just reject them completely
we won't even bring them in as a proper
input so I like this cartoon it says I
love your work they're family they're
supposed to say that all their friends
there have to say that there are
strangers they have to say that and when
I saw this tweet you know I liked to
read through some of the comments and
one person wrote you missed a frame and
so they created this frame
this is confirmation bias both sides of
it and really like their their response
so to compensate for this what I want
you to do is to create a positive
feedback board so anytime you get some
positive feedback I know it may not
register correctly write it down put it
on your wall and just save it there for
later I you shouldn't expect other
people to write these notes for you but
write them for yourself just write your
note you did a great job in that project
it doesn't matter how you feel about it
at that point just put it on the wall
the next time you need a little boost of
confidence look at your positive
feedback board alright next I want to
talk about self doubt now if you've ever
seen the awkward Yeti you'll know that
all of our cartoons have a brain and a
heart and so the brain is saying to the
heart the feelings may be easier if we
put this down so what I want to kind of
talk about is that this self doubt
becomes this coping mechanism that helps
us deal with the fact that we may not be
able to live up to this high standard
that we've set for ourselves and let's
go through what happens with someone
that has maybe a lower confidence of
course they're gonna have some uneasy
feeling they'll start to question
themselves you know I don't know what
I'm doing here I don't know what I'm
doing do I belong I'm really not as
smart as everyone else and that leads to
this negative internal talk I'm not an
I'm an imposter I'll probably gonna fail
at this I'm not good enough you know I
shouldn't even start because I can't
even do it right and even if the event
leads to success the success is
discounted as luck and if there's
failure well then the loop starts over
again but let's look at someone with
higher confidence yes they have
self-doubt yes they have uneasy feelings
and yes
they question themselves but here's
where the difference happens how they
respond to this self question this
self-questioning is healthy it means
wait I need to pay attention here
something's something is wrong
what what can I do about it and what I
do is I see this as an opportunity to
learn I have a growth mindset I view
this as a challenge something that I can
take on I'm gonna start researching
gather evidence ask questions I'm going
to look at maybe there's a buyer that
have and try to break that buy it gonna
create some goals around maybe there's
something I can do better here and try
to do it better next time they're okay
with failure I mean if you think about
us in the software world we're always
talking about fail fast they know that
if they fail fast they'll learn from
that opportunity and then iterate and do
it better next time and if they do have
success they take it on accept it they
own it this is something that I did and
they allow themselves to increase their
own their own self esteem and their
confidence will grow so very similar
concepts a couple weeks ago I was
talking to a skydiver and I was like
there's no there's no way I could ever
do this if I ever saw land like that
there's no way I'm too 8 you scared
falling is there's no afraid of heights
Freight falling there's no way I could
do this and what he said in response to
that really stuck with me it's not that
I no longer have fear I just know how to
manage it better that's the same with
highly confident folks they still have
fear they just know how to manage it
better so what I've done to help us move
from maybe a lower confidence to a
higher confidence is to create a growth
mindset worksheet this is just some of
the questions that you'll see on the
worksheet this will help you journal and
write about your thoughts and feelings
questions about what what do you think
Scott going to go
what do you think will go well how have
you prepared yourself for this and
there's a before something happens and
after something happens part of this
journal yeah we used to say when we were
a kid I can draw all I can draw give me
Jimmy's paper and then as we start
learning about masterpieces and the
complexity of art and brushes and things
like that we start to say well I can't
draw I can't draw but it's not that we
can't draw you can draw a few it's just
you needed practice right so the right
answer is I can't draw well right now
but I could if I wanted to and hopefully
as you work through these things you'll
be more confident to deal with whatever
comes your way
Tim Doherty this morning said concrete
failure is better than just some unknown
sense of failure and I think that's what
this worksheet does his talk was about
TDD that you know what the tests are
they're failing therefore I know what I
need to fix the same idea here we had
this unknown sense of failure I don't
really know why but I don't feel
comfortable here this makes you write
out your thoughts and really understand
why you feel this way so if you're an
impostor if you're impostor no you're
not if you're an individual contributor
tell your impostor story now this
doesn't have to be on the channel here
but we do have a slack channel during
the conference tell somebody tell
someone you're familiar with tell them
you're working through this worksheet
and you need their help make sure you
understand where your bias is where your
confirmation bias may be and of course
having a growth mindset is important
understanding that you can fail that's
okay that you can iterate and ask
questions you know not everyone is is
good at communicating knowledge and so
it's important that you ask questions
asking questions is a is an important
way to learn I mean think about little
kids that's all they do is ask questions
understanding that you have to embrace
this feeling of not knowing
and it's see it as an opportunity to
grow as we mentioned keeping that
positive feedback board and on your
successes these are yours I think it's
important to also compliment other
people when you see people that do know
something more than you do tell them I
really admire how much you know about
that can I learn from you and I think
it's important for you to men mentor
others I've been a big brother in the
Big Brother Big Sister Sister Sister my
I think that's extremely valuable and
then finally as I kind of mentioned back
when we did the tweet define your unique
perspective what is it about you what
about your background about the things
that you know your unique combination of
things that gives you value and if there
are any leaders in this room I want to
just mention a couple more points
tell your imposter story especially to
your directs bounce credit back don't
take it from your direct reports make
sure that you tell them that you
appreciate their work and from time to
time tell them exactly what it is that
you appreciate that they bring to the
team the expertise ability to follow
through their motivation or
organizations whatever it is make sure
you tell them because they're probably
going to write it down on a post-it note
and put it on their board so let's see
what we covered so you are not an
imposter feelings are not facts and
break out of this self-doubt loop and I
have some resources here for you if
you're interested in getting the slides
later thank you
[Applause]
[Music]